welcome back this is the Ben Shapiro
show we're taking your calls at eight
five five two three six thirty two
twenty eight that's eight five five two
three six a thirty to twenty eight chain
in Delaware you're on the bench Shapiro
show go for a chain hey Ben thank you
for taking my call
before I get to the question I just want
to tell your thumbnail team I'm not a
communist or a socialist so I'm you
destroy me don't put it in the thumbnail
okay you know no promises we'll try not
you I wanted to ask you uh do you ever
see if there's any like way capitalism
could uh maybe exploit eight people in
the third world maybe like people like
Nike that use like sweatshop labor and
do you think that conservatives
sometimes maybe shy away from the
problems capitalism can bring just so we
don't like maybe get some creating
smitty communism socialism well so one
of the problems that you have in in
third-world countries is typically that
the regime in charge is not engaging in
capitalism they're engaging in
corporatism or state what they built
wrongly term state capitalism meaning
they're there already
imposing tremendous restrictions on
their workers they are there deciding
which people can go into which lines of
work they're restricting trade
tremendously so that's not a problem
with capitalism that's a problem with
the inherent regime so for example you
start to sweat a sweatshop you know
clothes sweatshop in China
well China is dictating the labor that
can be provided to that sweatshop and
they are cramming down rates
specifically because they wish people to
invest in sweatshops in China if China
were free then presumably even be able
to pay people these unbelievably low
rates of labor in order to low rates of
pay in order to pay them to do the job
so it's not a problem with capitalism
that's a problem with China not being
capitalist enough now is it true that
there are profit seeking companies that
take advantage of that sort of thing
yeah absolutely but that's that calls
for more capitalism not less it means
that you would hope the cab that the
China would become more capitalist not
less so I think what people do is they
tend to mislabel the problem as a
capitalist problem as a process as
opposed to a profit-seeking problem you
see this a lot in American business to
China so one of the things that you see
is big companies that will work with
government to achieve a monopoly right
this does happen a lot right they'll get
they'll get regulations drawn that
specifically make it harder for people
to enter a given industry and people say
well look at capitalism it works like
nope that's not capitalism that is a
corporate that's a corporation engaging
in so-called regulatory capture it is
the opposite of capitalism which is
about free markets and free labor and
free movement of people and goods so
anything that cuts against that is
actually a problem with the opposite of
capitalism as far as the notion that
that people who are seeking to pay
extraordinarily low wages in a in a
climate of non compulsion so let's say
that you have in excess of labor rather
this how you get a low wage or you have
an excess of labor in particular area so
have a lot of people who are capable of
selling socks and now you only have to
pay people a very small amount of money
in order to sew socks now presumably if
that's their only job you're still gonna
have to pay them enough to live on these
otherwise they literally would not be
able to take the job but the the case
for capitalism even in that case would
be that if the alternative is that those
jobs just don't come to that area then
the alternative is unemployment not a
higher wage so people never look at the
alternative to people earning a wage
that they don't like which maybe them
not earning a wage at all which is one
of the reasons why you see folks on the
left constantly pushing the idea of
minimum wages neglecting the fact that
when you raise the wages arbitrarily
what you end up doing is helping people
who get to retain their job but hurting
everybody else you just lost their job
chain oh yes certainly yeah yeah I
totally agree with everything you just
said what I was gonna say uh crap forget
oh no worries yeah you think companies
that like not Walsh addresses on the
show I'm a couple days ago you said that
uh sometimes conservatives people had a
really profound
maybe not you but sometimes like people
are like very Pro callously uh sometimes
don't like to point out the greed some
billionaires had like Matt Walsh kind of
said like okay like you could if you
have eight billion dollars like you
could have three houses like that but
I'm like we have to say that kind of
greedy you could give that to them give
that money to do the poor obviously yes
I fundamentally disagree on this point I
don't think that it's greedy for you to
use your money basically however you
legally can and I don't think it's
immoral for you to buy an extra house
from somebody which raises real-estate
prices and does employ people I think
that the the notion that you owe the
money back to you some sort of common
fund I don't think is is correct like
listen I would
that people give more charity I should
give more charity I give a fair bit of
charity I should certainly give more
charity I think it's a good thing to do
I think that it's great that people like
Bill and Melinda Gates they just gave
like a hundred million dollars to
coronavirus research like all of that is
wonderful but I don't think that there's
anything morally wrong with you
consuming products that are produced by
somebody else in a free exchange now
maybe if you are if you are a
quote/unquote more moral person then you
give more of your money to charity but
that's not something that can be
compelled and the default which is that
you don't have to give your money to
charity doesn't make you a bad person I
don't think that you're a bad person
just because you bought an expensive car
I think that you're a bad person if you
stole the expensive car I think you're a
bad person if you demand that you have
to put your hand in somebody else's
pocket so in other words there are
gradations of morality let's say the
highest level of morality is that you're
an absolute Saint you'll earn enormous
amounts of money through free exchange
and then you give away an enormous
amount of money like great I think
that's that that is the highest level
then there's the second highest level
which is you engage in business you have
created an enormous number of jobs you
made an enormous number of people's
lives better and then you don't get that
much charity right that's not great it's
not quite as great as you giving the
charity but it's still pretty great I
mean you did create an enormous amount
of wealth for an enormous number of
people and then there's the third level
which is the worst which is you just try
to take everybody else's money and that
of course is actively bad certainly
certainly I definitely agree with you
don't everything you said I mean I think
people like me see if you like even
billionaires with you know a lot of
assets houses cars like that they think
that they inherently stole it from
another person because they don't have
something because poor might not have a
house or a car but like again it's like
the only other options we have the
government redistributing things and
that that's no good right again I mean
we can urge people to be more more
generous with the wealth that they earn
but it is their wealth and by the way
this is the great lie about charity
charity does less for the world in free
markets it does for and aids is less for
the free world that has done
significantly less for the global
economy and for poor people for a right
which is direct charity does far less
for poor people than free market
capitalism Bill Gates has done more good
for the world in creating Microsoft and
he has through the Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation and he's given an awful
lot of charity the amount of good that
he's done for the world in creating
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
jobs and making businesses across the
globe
more efficient in creating supply chains
across globally that's been it
significantly better for humanity and if
Bill Gates had just been handed a
billion dollars in hidden givin it all
to charity Shane really appreciate the
call Kyle in North Carolina here on the
bench Shapiro she'll go for Kyle you
enjoy my my Epstein comments at the end
of yesterday when I called it but anyway
I watched the State of the Union address
last night
the only water show and everything yeah
I thought the speech was just phenomenal
as all you guys with we're talking about
I was wondering where and I know I have
a speech which was really really good I
was wondering where you where you think
that speech ranks and they're all time
like presidential speeches so in terms
of all-time best presidential speeches I
think you have to think in 50 years
there are people gonna read the speech
so the answer typically for state of the
union's is no it's very rare that you
have a State of the Union address that
actually ranks among the best
presidential speeches typically there
has to be some sort of inciting events
that makes people kind of aware that the
speech is important so first of all I
think that trumps most you know his most
memorable speech was actually the speech
that he gave in Warsaw talking about the
defense of Western civilization in terms
of historic speeches you're thinking
Washington's farewell address maybe the
first and second Abraham Lincoln
inaugural addresses the Gettysburg
Address
JFK's the his speech in Berlin the the
JFK speech about going to the moon
right those features that have a
specific topic that aren't typically
sort of State of the Union addresses are
the ones that are the most memorable
MLK's speeches obviously the the
Washington Mall speech and though those
are the ones that people are gonna
remember do I think that this ranks
among the all-time best presidential
speeches I'll put the top of the second
tier right I mean I think there's a huge
second tier like an enormous second tier
of good presidential speeches that
people don't remember but does it list
in my top 10 no does it list in my top
20 probably not is it is it you know the
second best speech the Trump has ever
given yeah absolutely
Kyle really appreciate the call we'll
get to more of your calls momentarily
but first let us talk about the earbuds
that you are currently using to listen
to the show so are you using the earbuds
that have the wires attached to them and
now they are all tangled up in your
pocket like the ones I'm talking about
right now you're gonna have to pull them
out of your pocket
you have to untangle them it's a pain in
the butt or do you have the
one-size-fits-all earbuds that don't
actually stick in your ear when you go
jogging when you go running or even when
you're just moving around the house
maybe what you need is a great pair of
earbuds that are going to be made to fit
your ear I mean they actually have a
variety of fits I'm talking about Rea
cons wireless earbuds they have no stems
they don't have any of the of the wires
attached and they come in a variety of
colors and as I say they provide a
variety of fit Rey Khan has just
released their best model yet the e25
they have six hours of playtime seamless
bluetooth pairing more bass and more
compact design that gives you a nice
noise isolating fit Rey Khan's wireless
earbuds are incredibly comfortable
perfect for on-the-go listening and for
taking phone calls unlike some of your
other wireless options recon earbuds are
both stylish and discreet again no
dangling wires no stems and you get a
variety of fits and a variety of color
choices get 15% off your order at buy
rake on Comm slash pen that's a bui are
a YCL ENCOM slash man for 15% off rake
on wireless earbuds buy rake on Comm
slash been taking your phone calls at
eight five five two three six a thirty
to twenty eight Savion in pittsburgh
pennsylvania here on the bench bo
struggle for it's a beyond my question i
guess was a little bit more of a
philosophical one i have one of my best
friends and we talk and have a lot of
great intellectual conversations i mean
one of the things we talk about a lot is
abortion and he disagrees with me at
abortion i agree with you on abortion
that you know life begins at conception
and we have a zygote you know that's
unique DNA to that human being and we
can't destroy it my question was do you
think it's okay to consider someone your
best friend if you fundamentally agree
on moral or ethical issues no i don't
think there's anything wrong with but
fundamentally disagreeing on moral or
ethical issues i just don't think that i
would take them as a moral guide i think
that having friendships with full
knowledge and clarity about exactly the
basis for the friendship makes a lot of
sense now i would assume that there are
certain moral issues on which you guys
agree that that are even more bedrock
than you know like abortion is pretty
bedrock issue for me but apparently
there are some things that you agree on
presumably which is what makes you
friends so for example you probably
agree on the value of disagreement right
which is a pretty basic one because if
you didn't agree on that presumably you
couldn't be friends right he'd be
chiding you all the time about being a
sexist or something presumably you agree
on sort of the the nature of how
conversations should go and so you enjoy
those conversations now so i think it's
harder to have
long friendships with people who
fundamentally disagree with you on the
nature of morale I think I think it is
the more difficult I think that over
time people tend to sort into
ideologically like minded groups and I
don't think that's necessarily a bad
thing I think that that people want to
hang out typically with people it's
easier for them to hang out with and you
don't want to constantly feel pressured
by people who are telling you that
you're an immoral jackass all the time
but does it make you a hypocrite
I'd only it makes you a hypocrite nobody
says you can't be friends with people
you disagree with right but saying like
like the philosophical definition I
guess look like a friend you know if
you're friends with somebody you should
be somebody I guess who you're
like-minded with and agree with on a lot
of things you know would you be friends
with somebody who is okay with you know
if you consider abortion murder and
they're murdering someone you know it's
like can you be friends and you call
somebody a friend if you consider them a
murderer I mean listen I spend enormous
amounts of time you know hanging out
with people who think that I am a sexist
because I believe in protection of life
I am friends with people who are
pro-choice to a certain degree right who
recognized the validity of my argument
and disagree with it that that's
something that is gonna happen every day
in American politics and I think that
probably that's a good thing I mean we
should be talking to each other if we
can't talk to each other we got a
problem in American politics
I will admit my definition of friendship
is is pretty loose right I'm I think
that people tend to bring break down
into two categories friends people and
family people I am definitely a family
person meaning I have like two or three
very close friends and I have my family
and that's it
I do not have a broad circle of
acquaintance I don't tend to spend time
with people outside of my family like my
best friend is my business partner we
haven't gone out to dinner in 11 years
like we don't go out to dinner I'd
rather be with my wife and my kids he
knows that right he's more of a social
animal I am NOT a social animal in that
way so my definition of friendship may
be looser like people all have a
conversation with but if you're talking
about like a friend who you hang out
every minute of every day with because
you know you guys are besties and you
want to spend all the time you can
together
I'd only makes me a hypocrite I just I
admire your I admire the the nature of
your friendship such that you're willing
to overlook basic moral disagreements in
order to spend time with the person
that'd be uncomfortable for me on a
personal level okay and I definitely
agree with you that we all grow and you
know your mind expands and goes but you
have in conversations with people that
you disagree with that definitely leads
more compromise or more of you guys
being on the same wavelength or learning
from each other so it's definitely good
to be around people that you disagree
with but I really do appreciate it well
say the unruly appreciate listening and
thanks so much for the call we'll get
some more of your calls at eight five
five two three six thirty-two